würde gerne noch mal verweisen am Anfang
darauf dass das hier durchaus die Woche
sozialpolitischer und
arbeitsmarktpolitischer Entscheidungen
ist neben anderen wichtigen natürlich
die wir auch nicht unterschlagen wollen
aber wenn man mal genauer hinguckt es
geht ja nicht nur um das Bürgergeld in
dieser Woche am Mittwoch hat die
Koalition das Wohngeld plus Gesetz
eingebracht es wird heute an diesem
Donnerstag unter anderem noch gehen um
den sogenannten dezemberabschlag der ja
auch zumindest sozialpolitischer Aspekte
hat außerdem die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes und ein Inflationsausgleich
soll geschaffen werden für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger also jede Menge
Themen auf diesem Sektor in diesen Tagen
hier im Deutschen Bundestag und die
ganzen Gemengelage beim Bürgergeld Hans
Werner fitkau haben sie gerade schon
hinreichend erklärt 68 Minuten Debatte
wird zwar gleich geben im Plenum und wir
haben noch 14 Minuten Vorbereitung auf
diese Debatte und ich freue mich dass
bei uns sind Dagmar Schmidt die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion und Hermann Gröhe ist der
der dieselbe Funktion in der
Unionsfraktion hat ihnen beiden einen
guten Morgen und Frau Schmidt es wird
viel Gere Regelsätze über Sanktionen
über Schonvermögen das sind alles
wichtige Aspekte beim bürgergeldgesetz
aber sollen sie eigentlich erreichen mit
dem Vorhaben ja ich glaube dass der
Zentrale Paradigmenwechsel ist der dass
wir nicht mehr drauf gucken die Menschen
irgendwie mit hohem Druck
schnellstmöglichen Arbeit zu bringen in
irgendeiner Arbeit sondern dass wir
gucken dass sie nachhaltig langfristig
in Arbeit kommen dass wir sie
qualifizieren darin unterstützen auch
gute Arbeit zu machen dass wir Sie
begleiten und dass wir eben nicht mehr
diesen drehtüreffekt haben wollen
schnell in irgendeiner Arbeit und dann
schnell wieder im Jobcenter sondern dass
wir wollen dass ihren eigenen Weg in
Arbeit gehen und dann auch in Arbeit
bleiben und ich glaube dass dieser
individuelle Ansatz des Förderns das ist
glaube ich der Paradigmenwechsel den wir
den wir heute beschließen
Abschaffung des vermittlungsvorrangs
sind wir habe ich als Stichwort da auch
gefunden und hin zur Förderung auch
geringqualifizierter Herr gröber spricht
dagegen es spricht nichts dagegen und
ist übrigens Praxis in vielen Jobcentern
dass wenn ein Leistungsempfänger
Weiterbildung machen möchte dass
selbstverständlich Vorrang hat für
irgendeiner Tätigkeit für uns gilt
Vorrang für Vermittlung aber bei der
Eingliederung in Arbeit will die Ampel
ein Haushalt beschließen der 600
Millionen kürzt wir müssen noch gerade
heute wir haben 1,9 Millionen offene
Stellen 900.000 Langzeitarbeitslose
alles tun damit Menschen Teilhabe in
Arbeit erfahren Unterstützung erfahren
wir müssen besser werden beim fördern
aber wir dürfen nicht nachlassen beim
fordern und deswegen geht das Bürgergeld
in die völlig falsche Richtung sie
meinen fördern ist nicht mehr
hinreichend weil der Vorhaben der
Koalition es gibt einen Bericht der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit interne
Revision wird das genannt da wird
kritisch bei euch was machen eigentlich
die Jobcenter und wenn es da heißt in 50
Prozent der Maßnahmen seien diese nicht
zielführend dann ändert daran das
Bürgergeld nicht genau gerade nein
lesen Sie bitte die Briefe ihrer
Personalräte brandbriefe die sagen
wörtlich wir unter Tränen und wir können
unsere Arbeit nicht leisten und ihre
Kürzung seid untragbar der
aber wenn nicht den Haushalt jetzt haben
sie ja heute nicht dem Haushalt sondern
heute habe ja genau hallo bitte ich
entschuldige warten bis wir den Haushalt
beschließen dann können wir das alles
noch mal aufmachen
jetzt haben sie meinen Interview
umgekrempelt ich wollte sagen das macht
aber nichts weil ich wollte zu dem Punkt
ohnehin nur wenn sie sich gegenseitig
ins Wort fahren können wir auch nicht
weiter ich habe zwar gesagt sie können
aufeinander reagieren aber da muss halt
immer nur einer reden jetzt kommen wir
jetzt Frau Schmidt kommen wir zu dem
Punkt schon jetzt Frau Schmidt kommen
wir zu dem Punkt von Herrn Gröhe und
jetzt darf ich Sie bitten irgendwie da
direkt drauf Bezug zu nehmen erstens ist
natürlich genau das fördern das was wir
in den Blick nehmen durch diesen
Kooperationsvertrag durch diese
Kooperationsvereinbarung die mir Wachen
wollen ist ja genau das zu gucken
individuell was braucht diese Person was
braucht der Arbeitslose Mensch wieder in
Arbeit zu kommen und wir haben das die
Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung deutlich
erweitert wir haben die Möglichkeit
geschaffen dreijährige Ausbildung zu
machen wir haben die Möglichkeit
geschaffen auch Grundbildung noch mal
ganz anders nachzuholen wir haben das
was wir gemeinsam gemacht haben beim 16i
nämlich ein begleitendes Coaching
alle Arbeitsmarkt und wir haben für den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt gemeinsam ein
Coaching ein begleitendes Coaching als
Instrument geschaffen dass die Menschen
unterstützt werden darin auch diesen Weg
zu gehen und das hat sich als sehr gut
erwiesen das haben wir jetzt sozusagen
auch für die anderen Möglichkeiten wenn
man eine Ausbildung macht erweitert also
sozusagen das ganze Repertoire an
Unterstützung ist deutlich erweitert und
es wird eben genau dadurch dass wir den
vermittlungsvorrang abschaffen auch die
Möglichkeit gegeben das zu tun was den
Haushalt anbelangt möchte ich Herrn
Gröhe bitten doch abzuwarten bis wir den
Haushalt beraten weil wir dann danach
noch mal drüber reden können ob dort
gekürzt wird oder nicht in der Zeit den
Haushalt und sie haben ein Haushalt
eingebracht der massiv kürzt bei der
Eingliederung in Arbeit und davon hat
sich niemand klar distanziert die
Jobcenter Personal hätte sagen
händeringend das ist unverantwortbar und
es nützt eben nicht ein Coaching ins
Gesetz zu schreiben und beim Coaching
und bei der Vermittlung 600 Millionen zu
kürzen und im übrigen reden Sie mit den
Praktikerinnen und Praktikern aus den
Jobcentern die sagen für die
hartnäckigen Verweigerer jeder
Kooperation braucht es dringend die
Möglichkeit Mitwirkung auch durch
Leistungskürzung gleichzusetzen haben
wir das ja und das wollen sie nicht nein
das schaffen sie weitestens anders
falschen falschen Behauptungen nein also
seit Wochen hören jetzt bitte ich aber
mal festzustellen wer hier dauernd ins
Wort fällt es gibt eine Ampel Angst vor
Argumenten und deswegen wird gebrüllt
beleidigt und schon auf dem Schulhof
weiß man Jan tschuldigung das Wort Hetze
das Wort Lüge das haben Sie von uns
Sozialdemokraten nie gegenüber gehört
und das war hier im Plenum zu hören und
öffentlich von ihrem Parteivorsitzenden
und dann glauben Sie im Ernst durch
Arroganz der Mehrheit im Bundestag
gewinnen Sie eine Mehrheit im Bundesrat
sie verweigern uns die Anhörung des
Bundesrechnungshofs es ist ein
unterirdische Kultur und diese fallen
mir dauernd ins Wort jetzt müssen keine
Argumente haben haben sie schlechtes
Benehmen jetzt müssen wir es mal
systematisieren mit dem schlechten
Benehmen nachdem was sie an
Falschbehauptung in den letzten Monaten
in die Welt gesetzt haben das ist schon
atemberaubenden wo es bei ihnen falsch
Behauptung gibt ununterbrochen wurde der
Eindruck erweckt wir sein gegen höhere
Regelsätze sie können heute dafür
stimmen sie werden heute gegen höhere
Regelsätze stimmen und das müssen sie ab
morgen erklären den Widerspruch den
Menschen erklären warum sie gegen den
Mindestlohn gestimmt haben warum sie
nicht auf eine Erhöhung auf 12 Euro
unterstützt haben damit genau die
Menschen die wenig verdienen mehr haben
damit die Geringverdiener unterstützt
werden damit genau diese Abstand
zwischen einem Regelsatz und einem
Einkommen größer wird und dann da haben
sie dagegen gestimmt und jetzt sagen Sie
aber dort wo wir den Regelsatz erhöhen
wo sozusagen der Abstand dann wieder
geringer wird das müssen wir jetzt
sofort machen natürlich machen wir das
aber wir machen das im Gesamtpaket wir
machen das eben mit dem Stärken des
Forderns wir machen das eben mit der
Erhöhung des Regelsatzes wir machen das
alles gemeinsam so mit dem fortschreiben
der Dinge die auch wichtig sind für die
die gearbeitet haben und die sich schon
etwas aufgebaut haben die schon etwas
geschaffen haben damit dass wir das was
wir auch gemeinsam gemacht haben in der
großen Koalition nämlich dass wir eine
Karenzzeit für diejenigen haben die
schon etwas geleistet die sich etwas
geschaffen haben dass die nicht gleich
alles verlieren alles das ist sozusagen
ein Gesamtpaket und über das Gesamtpaket
reden wir dann auch gerne mit den
Ländern so und jetzt haben wir es glaube
ich jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen Ruhe
reingebracht da verstehen die Leute ja
auch viel mehr wir Herr Gröhe wenn sie
direkt noch mal erwidern wollen ich
würde dann gerne einzeln also
für 12 Euro Mindestlohn sind wir halten
die Entmachtung der Sozialpartner von
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgebern für
falsch zweitens das ist ein Problem gibt
das räumt Herr Gabriel ein ehemaliger
spd-vorsitzer der da verwarnt ist lohne
sich nicht mehr zu arbeiten das erklärt
der Bundesrechnungshof und das erklärt
Christian Lindner wenn er sagt die
Erhöhung der Regelsätze machen zwingend
eine Erhöhung des Grundfreibetrages
erforderlich es geht uns darum übrigens
auch die Bundesagentur für Arbeit
schlägt ein schrittweises Inkrafttreten
an jetzt sicherzustellen dass am 1
Januar höhere Regelsätze gezahlt werden
dass ein kluger Kompromiss neben sich
die Ampel verweigert wir haben ja einen
schrittweises in Kraft treten indem wir
zum Beispiel die Dinge wo der Jobcenter
sich darauf vorbereiten muss die sind
erst sozusagen für den Sommer vorgesehen
aber darauf muss man sich eben
vorbereiten und zum Vorbereiten das
wissen sie auch braucht man eine
gesetzliche Grundlage und genau deswegen
schaffen wir die zum ersten ersten
es wäre wünschenswert gewesen wenn die
Ampel in den letzten Wochen einen
Versuch unternommen hätte sachlich über
die grundsätzlichen Webfehler zu
diskutieren bereits
Beitrag zur sachlichen Diskussion das
nenne ich schlechtes Benehmen also wir
haben die Länder der Union haben vor
einer Woche der Koalition ihre
grundsätzlichen Kritikpunkte übermittelt
um die Chance einzuräumen uns ein
Vermittlungsverfahren zu ersparen und es
vor dem Bundesrat zustimmungsfähig zu
machen das hat die Ampel nicht genutzt
das stimmt
ja Reaktionen gegeben darauf es hat mir
Vorschläge gegeben
die Länder werden das bewerten die
zentralen Kritikpunkte von Sanktionen
bis schon Vermögen werden in dem
Entgegenkommen dem vermeint dem
überhaupt nicht adressiert also das
stimmt nicht und deswegen wir sind in
einem Zeitplan der knapp ist das gebe
ich ihnen zu 1 Januar ist knapp aber es
war der kabinettszeitplan der Ampel es
war der parlam Zeitplan der Ampel und
jetzt versuchen Sie damit uns unter
Druck zu setzen weil ihnen die Argumente
ausgehen beleidigt der klingenball Frau
Schmidt
also stimmt
ja es stimmt ja einfach es stimmt ja
einfach wieder nicht wir haben ja über
das Wochenende sind wir auf dem
Bundesrat zugegangen haben Kritikpunkte
aufgenommen und das übliche ist dass es
darauf dann sozusagen eine Reaktion gibt
und man dann sagt was Dankeschön dass
ihr auf uns zugekommen seid das und das
sind noch unsere Anliegen leider sind
die Gesprächsangebote die wir gemacht
haben nicht angenommen worden das kennen
wir aber schon und insofern hoffe ich
dass wir jetzt eine muntere Debatte
haben werden aber das danach alle wieder
zur Vernunft kommen und wir dann
wirklich diese sachliche Debatte mit den
Ländern führen können damit wir am 1.1
für die Menschen was Gutes hinkriegen wo
muss es sich denn an ihrer Meinung nach
Herr Gröhe bewegen dass der vielleicht
auch noch mal Bewegung reinkommt in der
derzeitraum ist ja in der Tat jetzt
relativ eng der Zeitplan ist der
Zeitplan der Ampel wir haben die
Kritikpunkte benannt als Unionsfraktion
die Arbeitsministerin und
Arbeitsminister der Union ich habe die
drei zentralen Punkte schon Vermögen
Karenzzeit und den weitestge Verzicht
auf die Möglichkeit von Leistungskürzung
ausdrücklich genannt und in diesem
Bereichen wird nichts geändert es sind
andere Punkte rehader greifen Sie
Vorschläge der Unionsfraktion auf das
ist in Ordnung aber in den zentralen
Kritikpunkten gehen Sie nicht auf die
Länder zu und das haben sie zu
verantworten und deswegen ich rate mal
jetzt langsam die Beleidigung
einzustellen wenn es zu einem
Vermittlungsverfahren kommt sollte man
nicht vorher schutzwegräumen müssen weil
man persönlich herabsetzend
Unionspolitiker als Trump als lügener
als Hetzer bezeichnet solche Töne haben
sie von niemanden gegenüber Hubertus
Heil oder Lars Klingbeil gehört es ist
einzig und allein die Ampel der die
Argumente ausgegangen sind muss man
vielleicht für den Hintergrund noch
erklären die den allen Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauern die da der direkte Bezug
fehlt der Hintergrund war waren
Behauptung die es gegeben hat oder
Aussagen aus der Union dass man mit
ALG2 mit Hartz IV besser leben kann als
wenn man tatsächlich arbeitet da gibt es
allerdings natürlich Studien die das
Gegenteil belegen und da gibt es glaube
ich auch einzelne die mittlerweile
einräumen dass es dann in der Tat nicht
ganz so schlimm es gibt unterschiedliche
Studien einige sind zurückgezogen es ist
sehr kompliziert zu berechnen weil es
mit Wohnungen muss alles Beton Geld
bezieht übrigens der Arbeitnehmer der
solche Hilfen in Anspruch nimmt muss
dies im Einzelnen beantragen im
Einzelnen bedarfnachweisen all das was
man in anderen Fällen für unzumutbar
hält aber entscheidend ist doch von
Sigmar Gabriel bis zu Christian Lindner
sagen alle das Problem existiert
wirklich und das einfach in Bausch und
Bogen als Hetze abzutun ist unanständig
und Entschuldigung der Vergleich zur mit
Herrn Trump der eine Abwahl nicht
anerkennt dessen Fans das
parlamentstürme durch ein klingen bei
ist das ein Angebot zum Kompromiss das
ist die Angst vor Argumenten durch
billige Sprüche aber jetzt haben sie
nicht dass die Union teilweise
werden wir als Hunde bezeichnet Frau
Schmidt das Benehmen der
Sozialdemokraten ist kein
kompromissstand das Gefühl ich habe das
Gefühl dass wir leider wieder nicht in
der Lage sind über die Sache zu reden
ja aber ich habe ich glaube sie haben
trotz dass ich ein paar Mal deutlich
machen musste dass sie etwas erzählen
was nicht stimmt genug Zeit gehabt ihre
Punkte zu machen insofern so glaube ich
dass das schon Frau
jeder Sekunde hier der Gong ertönen wird
und weil wir heute pünktlich im Plenum
sein wollen aus verschiedenen Gründen
vielen Dank Frau Schmid Hermann Gröhe
ist schon auf dem Weg vielen Dank auch
Ihnen das war ein Vorgeschmack meine
Damen und Herren auf das was Sie gleich
hier 68 Minuten lang im Plenum erwarten
können da wird es ja gewaltig hin und
her gehen sage ich mal vorsichtig